I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense let's talk about one that costs
four and a half million dollars to go to
lunch with okay you probably know who
that would be mr. Buffett yes okay I
just read that just this morning that
someone paid 4.5 million dollars to go
to lunch and this is someone that I
would you call my friend yeah a friend
and a mentor and how they how did that
happen
I'm actually having dinner with them
here in the next few weeks in Omaha you
know what happened was in 2001 when I
left the Seattle Mariners I was a free
agent and I signed with the Texas
Rangers and I signed for two hundred and
fifty two million dollars and I couldn't
believe when they told me that I'm like
what if someone's gonna pay me of that
mm-hmm
are they drunk there's a weight that's
carried with that oh yeah it was
enormous like you know Tom Hicks who is
now a good friend and someone who I look
at as a mentor and in his entire family
this incredible weight that goes with
that and there's a stress level and I'm
used to just playing baseball not being
an enterprise so and it was probably too
much too early I was only 24 25 I mean
like what but Warren ironically enough
because the contract was so large no
one's asked me about this before it's a
great question
we needed the last three years of a
10-year contract to be insured and the
last three years are always the most
expensive and and the most baseball
thing or is this a youth thing why does
there need to be insurance so let's just
say that I paid Annika a hundred million
dollars I would pay an insurance policy
say Jeff over there or Ron I would say
Ron I want you to insure my contract
with Danica if anything happens to her
my thirty million dollars then it pumps
he'll pay her salary so I'm insured that
if you're healthy I'm good
but if you go down then Ron insurance
pays for your contract then I'm off the
hook right so because this contract was
so large Warren Buffett ended up
insuring it and in the contract was
approved because they had four
and then thank God for Warren right when
I heard this story I was like what
that's cool that's so sick that's so
cool so I of course cold email like I do
all the time to people and that takes
guts and I'd say about that that's never
thinking that I would get I'm Alex
Rodriguez from Miami
why is Warren Buffett whatever and to my
email um I was a kid right and Debbie
who's still there she's been there many
many years just warned you know chief of
staff running the running camp down in
Omaha she wrote back and she goes yeah
Warren would love to see you and house
the next few weeks I'm like I'm there
I'm there yes yes yesterday and then I
ended up going you know a handful of
years back to back to back to to spend
four or five hours with him and our
running joke was like you're insuring me
I'm training my ass off yeah sweating my
ass off so you your money's good with me
and that was he was training erratum I
need you to do a hundred push-ups just
to make sure this insurance is good
that's right when we would order he
would say well make sure you give him
some vegetables cause yes
what I mean was it like a review I mean
like you said did you meet with him
every year you said probably
so was it some kind of like did you have
like the ultimate year-end review with
Warren Buffett or was this just like hey
we're buddies let's get to know each
other better or was there a agenda I
mean I would just say it's a little bit
of combination of all of that but of
course you can't sit down with Warren
for four hours and I'd say hey what do
you I'm gonna give you a union review of
what we're doing kind of what your
overall thoughts he would kind of dig in
a little bit with me and give me some
great suggestions and requests some
things and it was like amazing it was
one that was like I mean if there's
things that stand out and are other
things that he gave you a suggestions
that you thought to yourself I'm
speaking from experience like were you
thinking that's probably not a good idea
that's not gonna work or why would I do
that and then you do it you're like oh
my god it really should start listening
to people it was funny yeah there's a
few but the one thing that I said as I
left his office in Omaha I said you know
Warren can you give me some advice kind
of
into the season whether spaceball or
business or family and he goes yeah I
said hold on let me take out a pen and a
piece where I gotta write everything I
forget anything so take out a pen and a
paper yeah he goes oh you won't need
that it's super simple
I go okay he's like put it down I go
okay I put it down he goes number one be
the best baseball player you can be and
finally number two he goes be a
gentleman I go that's it he goes yeah
hold on let me write that down so I
wrote it down and wait talk about
simplicity right be a good baseball
player and be a gentleman
and he's right
[Music]